all units attempted 10:30 Charlie Bodega
on Smith purpose heading East on Baltic
that's us we're on
Baltic oh crap that was
him and
[Music]
stopy stay down oh damn sge maybe I do
like the sash can we all get back to
police work and stop talking about
wedding dresses no we're going to talk
about them because while wearing a
wedding dress you leapt over a couch
sprinted down an alley and jumped off a
car to subdue the crap out of a per like
you were Wonder Woman was pretty cool
wasn't it Amy you are an amazing cop and
a great leader and you have proven that
a billion times over you can't let other
people's opinions get in the way of what
you want especially because other people
suck well if I'm being honest I would
like a prettier dress there you go and I
would like it to have some lace uh-huh
and a sweetheart neckline thank you very
much what else and I want a mermaid cut
with tulip sleeves say it again say loud
a mermaid cut with tulip freaking
sleeve NYPD NYPD split out cover the
exit please Captain Captain he's not
getting away he took my dog oh my God
it's
happening
oh I see you have a knife but what you
need is an umbrella tell them why tell
them why cuz there's a storm going to
rain down on you
punk
my
[Music]
goodness you took the wrong fluffy
[Applause]
boy he's done CLE yes
sir ho ho
[Music]
ho let the
bo hey
Matt that'll teach you to have a dumb
normal name so you're a
cop I hate cops they gave me this nice
finally a good bad guy this dude gets it
now I'm going to kill you okay you took
it a little too far maybe scale it back
sco all set down
here okay start loading out I just have
one piece of business to take care of
you know killing a man is not as easy as
it sounds I've killed 10 men and that's
such a nice round number when you agree
I mean imagine I've killed 11 people it
just sounds so
cumbersome yippy kayak other the buckets
boil you did it and you completely
botched the catchphrase I'm pretty sure
it was right no but you did great so we
don't know if anyone helped George dudy
escape from this hospital security
cameras show him entering this Courtyard
but never coming back out dude just
vanished Terry hates hospitals they
wreak of
death oh not you ma'am you wreak of
Life maybe he went up the wall like
this never mind it's not possible
sure damn Rosa how did you do that I
have a dark
past
now you know my deepest shame cool well
now that I saw you do it I get how to do
it
too oh damn Terry Kevin is the captain
home no good I figured out what happened
to him he was mugged what he told you
this no I used my detective skills as
well as my spot-on Holt impression to
figure it out I retraced his steps and
found security footage after he left
fencing three Shady guys followed him
into an alley one of the them had a
knife that's why he's been in such a bad
mood he's a police captain that got
mugged he's embarrassed oh my goodness
for all there he is what are you doing
in my house Raymond you were mugged what
what did you say to him Captain it's
okay there's nothing to be embarrassed
about I'm not embarrassed and I wasn't
mugged three men tried to mug me but I
fought them off injuring two of
them wait so you heroically fought off
three guys and that put you in a bad
mood if I did that I would literally
write a song about myself it would be
like Jake the hero abs of steel sh la la
why would you keep this from me and why
would you lie about going to fencing
because he couldn't go because he's
injured I wasn't injured I was lightly
stabbed I'm sorry you were stabbed
lightly stabbed I sent him home he
assaulted Jimmy Broan yeah but that
caveman kind of had it coming don't you
think oh he didn't tell you tell me what
never mind if Jake didn't tell you tell
you he must have had a reason it's not
my place I'm disappointed in you
Santiago I thought you and I were
close I know you're manipulating me but
I love it and I will tell you anything
so Jake went to the schitz to talk to
Broan what are you going to do about
it there's nothing I can do except to
ask you nicely as a fan of you your work
and the guys you wrote about please
don't print the quote jez I didn't
realize you were going to get your
patties all in a pretzel that's actually
not technically possible I'm not wearing
underwear I just swampy in here my
butt's like the Everglades look I know
you're trying to be legit in a hairbag
world so I will not print your quotes oh
thank you thank you that means the world
to me and for the record I know that Hol
is a stickler but he's actually a really
good cop well don't worry about it we're
friends you don't have to stick up for
that
homo I really wish you just said that
what
homo thank you Santiago that'll be
all all right we need to distract them
do you have anything I can throw I have
a dog tag that is badass boy nope it's
an actual tag for a dog yep Molly she
was my poodle growing up never forget
your first your first one dog that is
never what people mean by
that
when you get to Hell say hi to Molly
what why is Molly in hell cuz it sounds
cooler than
Heaven door kick what's up dude is it
lunchtime is the drill over we're
freeing you guys Jake can you hear me is
it lunchtime no it's not lunchtime it's
10:30 in the morning no wonder I'm
starving look we came here to win and
they're not even giving us a chance I
think it's fair to say that no one in
the history of America has been
discriminated against more buddy yeah
that's my be adrenaline talking so you
guys in I don't know I don't want to get
in trouble oh wow you sound like a real
Terry why don't you just take your shirt
off and make your pecs bounce around
again the adrenaline don't sue me look
you two are still arguing about who gets
Saturday off right mm highest body count
wins done I'm going to vape you like my
EIG okay you basically just lost 99 we
are hostages no
longer now really meant to rip off the
whole thing but I say we go with it come
with me
[Music]
ho
Diaz 42 Santiago Jake this is great I
shot a guy in the face he is so mad at
me nice all right this hallway is clear
I think we killed them all it's a
regular paint bath like bubble bath no
like blood bath yeah all right meet in
the basement here we
go
yeah okay me and Bole took down six Rosa
and Amy got four 14 Hitchcock and Scully
we're killed immediately yeah we're dead
we also disarmed and captured all these
guys so is that all the terrorists not
quite drop your weapons everybody drop
them right now it's over you lost drop
them now or this man you're dead crap
sack all right sge you decided to be
cool I'm always cool I also couldn't
spend another second listening to those
ATF wads and moan leave it to the
NYPD to screw up being hostages I
thought cops love to sit around on their
fat asses all day and do nothing that's
it whoa my ass is not fat kind of sounds
like it was just about your weight
issues